dans ta carrière ça fait énormément duo
je vais te proposait de revoir les trois
duos et trois duos les plus mythiques de
ta carrière pauvres j'en ai choisi un
c'est johnny abri quant à chanter le
titre je te promets on a acheté l'image
c'est pas pour le mettre à le voir
garder au dessus de tout
et des dentiers
pour que telle soit
addou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mazel jennifer
merci jennifer charron
mais j'avais quand même chanson pour
valérie benaïm je te promets une
augmentation jamais arrivé jennifer tu
as rencontré johnny pour la première
fois c'était en corse c'est ça j'étais
très petit moi je sais il paraît qu'il
était venu manger dans un village à côté
il était allé le voir
on est tous allés le voir on trouve très
très embêté parce que j'étais il était
off il était en repos total
et puis il avait envie de passer un
moment sauf qui s'est tapé tous les
gosses du village une palais pour johnny
hallyday c'était l'événement dans son
village
et ouais ouais donc on avait fait la
photo pour le pour le corse matin et
j'avais osé mettre ma main comme ça mais
alors que je n'osais pas y aller une
fois que je me suis retrouvé à côté de
lui je me suis quand même cette jolie
idée je vais le voir qu'une seule fois
dans ma vie puis finalement c'est enfin
parce que c'est vrai que derrière un
vieux nice et rien qu'en dès qu'il
arrive dans le village avec tous les
enfants les lois cc contraire de
matthieu delormeau tous les enfants tous
les enfants quittent le village toutes
les personnes fascinées et là tu es là
ça devait être un grand moment pour toi
mènera à oui c'était c'était un des plus
beaux moments de sa qu'on l'a
sélectionné alors y en a un autre qui
l'a sélectionné qu'on a sélectionné
c'était ton tube donne moi le temps
chanté avec grégory lemarchal lors du
cinquième prime de la star ac 4
regardez jennifer et grégory
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deuxième c'est la deuxième chanson que
j'avais écrite pour valérie bénaïm donne
moi le temps de donner mon mandat fait
dix ans que ça dure et ça c'était un
grand moment
ah oui un très grand moment je te
connais très belle aussi la voilà c'est
gentil j'étais très très ému de chanter
avec et enfin jeu il ya eu un dernier
dîner à dire dernier duo que tu as fait
c'est avec slimane pour le titre les
choses simples sliman on adore c'est
vraiment je kiffe ce mec et ses
instances à un gros show je dois
regarder sur une surprise pour foyer
[Musique]
c'est humain
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
c'est bon
quelle claque on se retrouve le monde de
tubas et la fête je vais faire c'est
incroyable toutes façons c'est vrai on a
reçu rené la taupe on a mis un titre
george est un truc de ouf
un nouveau truc yahia on oublie le reste
il ya un nouveau titre exceptionnel une
collaboration avec kylie minogue qu'elle
est mignonne kylie minogue que j'aime
beaucoup
la champion français de l'aluminum elle
reprend qui reprend le mythique lalala
extrait de son single can't get you
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on sème en boucle en se collant ce qui
est au nom d'anne atomique à mort
héroïque dont 6 twh son fils
on est libre on se souvent nos espaces
trop bas de plafond
et pardon veut en faire
[Musique]
mais encore
on sèche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les sympathiques kylie minogue ou pas
elle est très sympathique série mais
jacky fois comme ça je connais pas mais
j'ai un bon a priori sa pratique
j'ai un bon a priori mais que très
intègre aussi
c'était lors de son contrôle fiscal
montaigne icône de la pop et je suis
vraiment très flatté qu'elle ait accepté
de compenser ce duo avec moi en fait en
pensant sur cette reddition
je voulais vraiment le prolongement de
ce que j'avais rencontre raconté dans
dans la première édition donc dans la
nouvelle page cette tournée qui a été un
magnifique je voulais vraiment que ça
que ça reste la fête et donc on
réfléchissait aux chansons il ya ce
refrain qui nous reviennent en tête à
chaque fois qu'on l'a là donc on a lancé
kylie minogue en un ami en commun c'est
par l'esa et puis elle est acceptée elle
a aimé la chanson elle est idiot tout de
suite très fort elle a posé le couple
alors nal message vidéo que kylie
minogue a envoyé à l'occasion de la
sortie sur les plates formes de votre
duo incroyable voilà c'est pour cela
qu'ils allaient envoyer sur les plates
formes il salue écoutez maintenant le
nouveau single de jenifer on oublie le
reste en duo avec moi kylie minogue
sa séance de novembre on a le combien la
crise donc vous comptez trois jours et
ça sort le titre est un carton à quand
on part en 2003 on soit peu
l'influencent britney spears nantes est
donc un petit côté écolière mais rebelle
genre qui se met au fond de la classe
côté radiateur mais qui est quand même
qui est quand même dans le chat doré
regardez ce clip hip hop voilà alors là
elle portait une petite bracelet en cuir
de vachette
non c'est très beau et ça c'était
magnifique vous savez ces vieux cons
truire tournée solo moi je sais
effectivement avec ce petit clip à mon
habitat pas dû rester sous l'eau
longtemps ensuite vous avez une époque
plus maritime un petit 6 regarder non
mais ça ne s'est pas mes vêtements
c'est un déguisement pour asseoir la
terre oui pour la victoire la terre de
yannick noah exactement voilà c'est ça
s'était déguisé pas d'accord ce que je
veux à part à la chasse à la palombe
lens
c'est un des gars ça vous va très bien
sur l'écossé cm et j'adore et la
casquette de type chauffeur de taxi
j'adore venir grotte avec sa soeur excès
oui il est excité gavroche avec la
moustache merci dans ces bombardements
en 2010 c'est l'année de la maturité on
est passé en mode femme fatale à la robe
bicolore
c'est quoi cette petite robe c'est du
velours lisse on al'occasion de
l'occasion de me faire prêter des
vêtements donc je m'amuse avec ses
magnifiques serait absent tu te vends
cette chance là tout va tout
non c'est au festival de cannes et
c'était à l'allianz arena de ces
allahyar has been que j'embrasse où il
est mort quand même
[Applaudissements]
et
[Rires]
on n'est pas au bar en 2000 où c'est un
des grands moments de ta carrière
sa véritable tournant puisque tu vis ta
première sélection avec l'équipe de
football du brésil
regarde le foot concert mais même comme
ça même comme ça tu es frêche je vais
t'appeler mart a voté frêche conscience
des gens mais je te jure et regardez
bien d'autres délires da et un autre
mythe un nouveau nom tu la joues
hyperclasse working girl avec une
nouvelle coiffure ça c'est mon appel à
moi j'aime bien c'est ce qu'on appelle
la coiffure gaufres est vers la manche
j'avais toujours là mais je dois
développer surtout c'est beau ça
toujours du mal à en fait à me voir en
photo mais a répété mme arena magnifique
je montais look dans de voiceage alors
the voice kids who the voice à chaque
fois on a le droit à des tenues de
dingue
c'est un rallye
après regardez ça c'était au vote 2017
tommy ouellet arrêt sur images
j'adore et aux nma 2019 alors l'achat ne
sais pas c'est beau ça diallo qui dit
qui dit je suis papa je crois que quand
on a le book de je ne suis que je t'aime
et samedi vous êtes allés chanter dans
danse avec les stars
oui avec un look seventies et encore on
en a pris ça y est c'est toi qui choisis
tout est tenu du 20 août à quelqu'un qui
te conseille je choisis avec sylvaine
qui s'accompagne depuis maintenant
presque 20 ans un monsieur qui m'a
énormément appris sur les modes sur la
coiffure au statut coiffure elle me
donne elle compte beaucoup pour moi
eh ben pour moi aussi et je te dire que
si je te dirai compte beaucoup pour moi
j'aime c'est injuste parce que j'imagine
tout s'est tenue avec daniel moreau ça
serait pas le même
[Applaudissements]
ces damnés son style et daniel moreau
est une très belle femme chérie ce matin
en bureau
sachez que mon sang n'a fait qu'un tour
les créateurs se bat pour pour habiller
jennifer sahel et icône de mode elle est
prêt et on commet toujours s'est tenue
ces sorties et se battre je repasse
juste mais je suis gentil merci beaucoup
mais je redis pardon vraiment je m'amuse
avec les vêtements
après je recherche pas l'avis unanime
j'ai besoin de me sentir bien dans mes
vêtements et de deux voiles à zeus et le
jeu selon les émissions selon ce que
j'ai remarqué de ce que j'ai vu ça j'ai
besoin d'amener les matières nobles
espèce
ces enveloppes pour être aussi beaux
tous les jours je vous dirais delphine
delphine is as we know conseil et
franchement depuis que suis avec elle et
je peux vous les ans a connu beaucoup de
la chemise est ce que tu m'as dit en
arrivant je risque pas de rentrée
je te trouve se trouve que plus affûté
que jamais merci fois encore à parler du
loup on m'appelle le couteau suisse dans
le métier